you know what i was thinking about when
you were kind of doing your elevator
pitch is um you know
we kind of have a similar story because
it was around 2012 that i
started to
get in the exit kind of space from my
debt relief business uh yeah and i think
we're the same age too rich yeah yeah
yeah and
it wasn't the housing market um
you know that i was looking into at the
time because i was a little delayed
until about 2015 and the full exit was
around you know 2018 or so but um
how how would you compare
running a company of 100 employees
to
trying to figure out the direction of
the economy and where to place your bets
with your own
money right like this is money that
you've that you've earned paid taxes on
and you want to deploy to
um you know go to work for you what's
that like trying to figure out the
economy versus trying to figure out how
to run a business like how would you
compare the two like other similarities
or the differences
oh complete opposites you know as as a
business
you know you're babysitting especially
when you got 100 employees
and you're managing people uh you're
trying to
problem-solve just constantly constantly
constantly putting out fires
and then you're trying to
uh take charge and grow the business in
whatever way that you can and try to
seize opportunity
but in investing
number one you don't have to deal with
employees and number two
instead of having that offensive
approach
with investing you got to have a
defensive approach first and foremost
you know you've got to manage risk
and the number one rule in investing is
just make sure you stay in the game
and uh you know warren buffett says
the top three things to remember in
investing is don't lose money don't lose
money and don't lose money
and
as you know as an entrepreneur you don't
have that mindset you have an abundance
mindset
and like i said earlier you're always
looking for opportunities to start a new
business to create a new revenue stream
and and you've got to
be willing to take an acceptable amount
of risk and often risk that other people
would see as excessive
and in in proper inve now speculation or
speculating is is different i think
there's a uh a component of risk there
that's acceptable but if you're just
investing and just trying to make a 10
or 12 return and uh
maintain your purchasing power first and
foremost
you've got to be always focused on your
downside always focused on risk
management instead of an entrepreneur
you know you're always trying to focus
on the upside
and
when it comes to putting money into the
markets wherever you deploy it i mean do
you do you just sort of dollar costs
average in
throughout the months and years or do
you look for buying opportunities when
there's blood in the street
yeah the latter so i i've always but
this is different you know based on
objectives and your personality you've
really got to know yourself well yeah as
an invest you got to know what your
strengths are what your weaknesses are
but you need to do that in
uh entrepreneurship as well
but i really just don't i tried not to
do anything you know going back to jim
rogers one of his famous lines
is
he always said that you gotta just wait
and sit on your hands be very very
patient and when a pile of money is
sitting in the corner just go pick it up
and then come back to your chair and in
the interim do nothing and sometimes you
go a year you go two years without
seeing a pile of money
show up in the corner but that's fine
that's okay so many people have this
itch to keep doing things and usually
that's counterproductive so as an
example
one of the first times i actually bought
shares was back in 2013
uh when cyprus had the bail-ins i don't
know if you remember that when they're
buying when they had their banking
crisis
and uh they actually you know took
depositors money
and uh their stock market went down by
99 percent
and you could go in there and buy
publicly traded shares of hotels as an
example you know cyprus is a big tourist
destination
and uh you know they were just trading
for pennies and you could get like a 10
15 dividend yield so i went and did that
just took advantage of crisis investing
if you will
and i've never stole the shares i i
still have them today and then
another example in march of 2020
when the the market was just in
dire straits because of what's called
the cerveza sickness uh there's there's
fear there's panic
that's another indicator i like to use
when
as far as on the buy side is when
there's panic you know you always want
to get greedy
and uh i was buying when oil was down
under 20 a barrel
i was buying oil producers when oil was
negative 38 a barrel if you remember
that
and uh i was buying uranium i was buying
a lot of the commodities because
uh at the time and and to this day i
think that we've gone into a commodities
super cycle
which usually usually lasts about
uh 10 to 15 years the last one started
in 96 98 and ended in 2011
and i think that we went into another
one in 2020 and will probably be in this
bull market super cycle until 2030 20 35
now it's not to say that there isn't
volatility there's always extreme
volatility where prices will go way way
up and then they'll come crashing down
but that's what you use as your buying
opportunity and kind of buy around that
long-term view but you got to be patient
to add to your position i think now is a
great time or a great example you know
we've got oil at a hundred and ten
dollars a barrel
and anytime oil gets over 80 or 85
adjusted for inflation
it's it's pretty expensive so i was
wanting to buy and i did
quite extensively when it was under 30 a
barrel and right now i'm not buying
definitely not selling but i'm waiting
for a pullback
if russia hopefully you know the russia
ukraine thing comes to an end very
quickly i think that makes oil drop down
to probably 80 that might be a buying
opportunity or
if we get a recession you know we had
the inversion of the yield curve in the
united states with the treasury market
the twos and tens maybe two months ago
uh we had a negative gdp print for q1 in
the united states
we've got a lot of indicators that are
screaming recession right now so if we
go into a recession especially as the
fed is raising interest rates that could
be very bearish for commodities but
again i think that's a buying
opportunity if you've got that long-term
10 to 15-year time horizon where we're
in this super cycle and you saw those
stages and those fluctuations in price
in the last one we went through from 96
to 2011 as well so that that's kind of
uh
the way i like to do things uh you know
another example of just buying cheap and
selling expensive is uh when i bought
real estate in 2012
i wasn't trying to figure out the price
and this is something i learned from jim
rogers as well
is i i don't think that's a a prudent
strategy because and that's what most
people do
first and foremost is they try to ask
themself well what's the price going to
do right if i'm buying a home in 2012 do
i think the prices are going to go up or
do i think they're going to go down if
the prices are going to go down then i'm
going to hold off and not buy if the
price is going to go up then i'm going
to go ahead and buy now i don't think
that's the right approach instead you've
got to just ask yourself a simple
question is it cheap
if it's cheap buy it regardless of which
direction you think the price is going
and if it's expensive sell it so in 2012
i thought the prices most likely were
going to continue to go down
but i bought anyway because it was cheap
and i just sold my last property in the
united states a couple months ago now
that's not because i think the market's
going to crash maybe i do maybe i don't
but the market could go up another it
could triple from here who knows but i
don't care about that because i'm just
selling because it's expensive
regardless of which direction i think
the price is going to go i think if you
continue to do that and you're agnostic
as far as your
uh the commodity or excuse me you're
agnostic as far as the
types of
assets you're willing to invest in and
where you're willing to invest you just
do that over and over and over again and
i think that's an edge and if you do
that over the long term i think you're
going to come out a winner hey guys i
really hope that you enjoyed that short
clip if you did consider supporting the
creation of content by checking out my
supplement line pinned in the top
comment below of this video in the
comments there's a link to the unplugged
alpha dot com forward slash shop when
you click through you'll be able to land
over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you